[Music]
this show right here it's not as
political as a lot of the other shows
out there we're not as political I think
we owe it to our viewers to at least
cover the biggest moments during the
election cycle I'm told by my producer
in a fake way there's a major
development currently happening is that
true
Wow
six years of acting school and that's
what I get oh what's that there's a
major development happening whoa okay
look at that okay let's go to our
election coverage right now
Conan's 2016 election coverage
Cody's 2016
there's another one check it out Rodin's
2016 election coverage
what Wow incredible war fake telling
look : is 2016 election coverage
[Music]
but last one those are the two most
depressing stuffed animal er ever seen
in my life
you